It actually happened to be on
the elevator with the representa
But Hosey,
who filed the resolution to expe
I greeted him
and I also asked him that he lea
anything from his experience.
He said that,
you know,
it's part of leadership's decisi
to kind of ask him to follow thi
And, you know, but besides,
that was very quiet.
But I think, you know,
the Republicans
are in a point of reflection
here in Tennessee that what they
they thought would happen
without any resistance.
But it has the world watching
what's happening here.
The speaker
of the House is trying to backtr
But like I said today,
you know,
we are calling for his resignati
He is an enemy of democracy
and he doesn't deserve to be
in that office of Speaker of the
any longer.
A lot of reflection
going on all over the country,
but especially there in Tennesse
Democratic Representative Justin
speaking last night,
entering the Tennessee House
that you're looking at now.
The chamber after the Nashville
Metro Council voted unanimously
to reinstate him on Monday.
Jones and his Democratic colleag
Justin Pierson, were expelled la
for violating decorum
during a gun reform
protest in the chamber.
Gloria Johnson narrowly survived
her removal vote
and walked in the
chamber by Jones's side.
Among the people that
was the people's house
a lot of old democracy
back to the people's house.
The so-called Tennessee
three could be reunited
tomorrow when Shelby County comm
will vote
on whether to reinstate Justin P
So joining us now, Tennessee
State Representative Gloria John
Thank you, Representative.
I appreciate you joining us this
As I said to you in the break,
because of what happened in Tenn
but also because of
what happened in Kentucky as wel
it is all connected.
We appreciate you joining us.
So you walk back into the chambe
arm in arm with your colleague
just in Jones.
What was that moment like for yo
It was it was just it just felt
It was so good
to have him back in the body.
Overwhelmingly supported
by not only his district,
but every district in Davidson C
And I just
I was I didn't know if that woul
that he would be back
or that
there would be any challenge to
And it was so nice because
because both Pearson and Jones's
voices are so important in our b
And we just need those young,
passionate voices
that are willing to fight
every step for their constituent
and put their constituents befor
lobbyists and corporations.
I want to ask you about
you've been very up front
after the vote last week
that you felt race played a role
and Pearson's removal.
But there are
some of your Republican colleagu
who are saying
the difference was in their esti
that it wasn't race
that you argued,
your attorney argued to the cont
that you never shouted
or pounded the podium
or displayed
a sign containing a political st
last week,
and also that you chose
not to participate in a letter
that their attorneys
had submitted,
that your attorney didn't take p
in that letter
that you submitted your own.
Do you still believe that it was
And how do you respond to your c
who are saying that
You know,
I've been sitting
in that body for a while.
I hear racist statements all the
And it was just a few weeks ago
that one of my colleagues
in our criminal justice committe
we were we had a bill
they have a bill to bring back
the firing squad and the electri
And one of my colleagues said,
I think we should bring back
hanging by a tree.
He literally suggested lynching.
I think it's very clear.
There have been statements
in committee for years,
and they've made themselves clea
If you heard the questioning
of those two
young men,
compared to my questioning,
you definitely heard
racially tinged questions.
It it's it's blatant, quite fran
Representative, do those stateme
make it onto the local media?
Would you like to see more cover
We just did a segment
a couple of minutes ago
about state legislatures
not getting the coverage
that is warranted.
And some of these things
going on in silos with people do
and saying reprehensible things.
Yes.
You know,
I think it's
critical that we have our eyes
on our state legislature.
That's that's where
that's where democracy dies.
That's where they're attacking
because they can in those red st
are the supermajority states.
And we've got to have our eyes
on everything that's happening t
because it is
you know, democracy dies in dark
And I feel like for a while
to read has had no eyes on
what's happening during COVID.
We didn't have
a lot of visitors inside the Cap
people couldn't come
if they wanted to come for gun
violence bills or,
you know, some of those things.
It was hard to get people to the
because of COVID.
Now that we've opened back up
and people are coming
in, it's great
to have those people's
voices in the hallways to remind
that that's who they work for
and not the lobbyists
and the special interest groups,
which is
I feel like, you know, their bos
Yeah.
You said democracy dies in darkn
Speaking of democracy,
Justin Jones has called
for a Republican speaker.
Tennessee House.
The Tennessee House.
Cameron Sexton
to resign, calling him
an enemy of democracy.
Do you also think Sexton should
Yes.
I mean,
you know, we
had a disgraced speaker right be
and he is doing many of the same
just not as zealous and openly,
But he has limited debate
to almost nothing on the House f
He may make up the rules as they
along.
You know, we asked for
B out to be able to show video
and we were told no video.
Then we come in
and the first thing they do
is make a motion to have video.
And of course, they have the vot
So they vote voted in their vide
But we weren't prepared for vide
because they had already told us
they changed the rules as they g
There's no debate our mikes are
We are
most often, you know,
not called on the other day
when America was watching.
We had more healthy debate
on bills before those
before the hearings.
We had more healthy debate on bi
than I think we've ever had.
In three years,
a three or four years on the Hou
because people were watching
because of what happened.
The legislature has been so divi
Do you think that
getting getting the people's wor
done is just going to make it
harder or easier moving forward
now that this controversy
has reached a worldwide audience
You know, that's an interesting
And I've been asked that questio
and I'm I'm hopeful.
I'm always hopeful,
but I'm hopeful that they're lis
that they're open,
that they realize perhaps,
you know,
we shouldn't stay with business
We should be a more deliberative
a more transparent body.
And I'm going to be hopeful
that it's going to happen.
It remains to be seen
how they actually handle this
as I use it as a learning experi
Hopefully, we will know soon
by being able
to to deliberate
and talk about some
of these gun violence,
gun sense
regulations and legislation
we want to put in
because we want to protect the c
You know,
I always hear, oh,
you know, don't talk about it ye
It's too soon.
But if you don't talk about it,
what we see is in the very next
or two,
we have another horrible inciden
of gun violence.
And so we do the time to talk ab
it is yesterday
because we have got to stop this
And I would hope
that my colleagues get on board
and help us
do something
that instead of beefing up secur
and having tanks
at schools,
as one of our members suggested,
we prevent guns from getting
to the schoolhouse door,
because if you're ready for a gu
at the schoolhouse
door, people are going to get hu
But we can prevent guns from eve
to the schoolhouse door
or to to the bank doors.
You know, that's what we want to
We want to work on prevention.
We don't want gun battles
at the schoolhouse door.
We will be watching
what happens in the Tennessee
legislature tomorrow
when there is a vote for Justin
reinstatement and beyond.
Thank you.
Tennessee State
Representative Corey Johnson.
We appreciate it. Be well. Thank